[Music]
bobert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy Financial Times reported recently
that the Trump administration is
considering dropping Pakistan as an ally
as it examines tough measures to quell
more than 20 terrorist groups it says
are based in that country here again the
president who is daily derided and
ridiculed by foreign policy experts is
right and they are wrong
Pakistan is no ally and has not been for
years this is a rupture that is
much-needed and long overdue President
Trump has accused the Pakistani
government of housing the very
terrorists that we are fighting and it's
true with the most notorious of these
being Osama bin Laden himself journalist
Carlotta gall who reported from
Afghanistan for The New York Times for
12 years reported in March 2014 that
soon after the Navy SEAL raid on bin
Laden's house a Pakistani official told
me that the United States had direct
evidence that the ISI Chief Lieutenant
General Ahmed Shuja Pasha knew of bin
Laden's presence in Abbottabad the
information came from a senior United
States official and I guess that the
Americans had intercepted a phone call
of Pasha's or one about him in the days
after the raid he knew of osama's
whereabouts yes the Pakistani official
told me the official was surprised to
learn this and said the Americans were
even more so he shouldn't have been it
had been obvious for years at that point
and remains obvious that the Pakistanis
had been aiding the same jihadists that
the US government had been giving them
billions of dollars to fight the New
York Times reported on that at length
back in 2008 not only did Achmed Shuja
Pasha the head of the Pakistani
government's spy Service is I know the
whereabouts of Osama but so did many
other top officials in the Pakistani
government those who were genuinely
surprised by this news probably also
think that Islam is a religion of peace
that's been hijacked by a tiny minority
of extremists after all this is the
country where the jihad
Chief Hafiz Saeed on whom the US has
placed a 10 million dollar bounty lives
openly and comfortably the International
Business Times reported as long ago as
three years ago that Saeed lives as a
free man in Lahore even though he is
chief of jamaat-ud-dawa a parent
organization of banned lashkar-e-taiba
the organization was implicated in the
2008 attacks on Mumbai in India which
claimed 166 lives not only that but
Pakistan has twice placed Saeed under
house arrest since 2001 but had let him
go under suspicious circumstances and
now J UD operates quite visibly in parts
of Pakistan with its own website and a
Twitter page none of this has changed in
the intervening three years the
Pakistani government meanwhile is
getting us money to fight terrorists now
this is what they're using it for Sky
News reported in January 2014 that
Pakistani officials have reportedly used
a secret counterterrorism fund to buy
wedding gifts luxury carpets and gold
jewellery for relatives of ministers and
visiting dignitaries now this is better
than funneling to the terrorists
themselves the money that the Pakistani
government received from the u.s. to
fight terror but it also shows how
seriously the Pakistani authorities have
taken their role in the war on terror
that is not seriously at all three years
have passed since these facts were
revealed the Obama administration of
course did nothing Trump's apparent
willingness to grasp this metal is
greatly to his credit for even as there
was an immense political shift in the
u.s. with the election of trump Pakistan
has been if anything consistent in
November 2013 after Pakistani Taliban
leader Hakimullah met Masood was killed
in a drone strike the Pakistani
government was furious and summoned the
US ambassador to protest the Pakistani
Foreign Minister Chaudhry Nisar Ali Khan
said the killing of Massoud was not just
the killing of one person it's the death
of all peace efforts and warned that
every aspect of Pakistan's relationship
with Washington we
be re-examined that is remember for the
death of a Taliban leader and in the
summer of 2013
Pakistan's aboutabout Commission which
was an investigation into the raid that
killed Osama bin Laden denounced the
u.s. as arrogant and said that the
killing of bin Laden was the greatest
humiliation that Pakistan had suffered
since the 1971 declaration of
independence by East Pakistan which is
of course now Bangladesh for far too
many years now the US government has
been suffering from a strange addiction
an addiction to shoveling huge amounts
of money to old Cold War allies that
aren't really allies at all anymore if
they ever were the end of this farce
with Pakistan should have come long ago
we can only hope that President Trump
will follow through on his remarkably
clear sided view of this sham ally I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]